you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's program
you wait years for an electric car
announcement and then two come along at
once
vauxhall's parent company follows nissan
in confirming
plans to switch its ellsmere port plant
to manufacturing electric vehicles
but could hydrogen cars be the new kid
on the green
vehicle block i'll be speaking to
presenter and proud hydrogen car
owner james may
and how communities around the uk will
be marking the great big
green week ahead of the cop 26 climate
[Music]
summit
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show
where we track the changes happening to
our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions
well last week it was nissan today it is
vauxhall's turn the car manufacturer's
parent company
is the latest to announce a switch to
electric vehicles confirming
that their ellesmere port plant which
currently produces the astra model
will change to making electric vans and
with new figures today
showing that more than 1 in 10 new cars
sold last month were electric it seems
like consumers
are starting to drive the change our
business correspondent paul kelso has
more
this announcement is big news for
electric vehicle production in the uk
because it concerns the production of
vans
and their passenger derivatives like
these there's a peugeot
brand we have a citroen brand here and
this is the vauxhall combo e and it's
significant because these are kind of
small vans that do so much home delivery
now with the rise
of e-commerce and moving that huge fleet
from diesel and petrol vans to electric
vans it's going to take the uk
a significant step down the road towards
minimizing
emissions now the plant here has been
here for
60 years they've always made internal
combustion engines
that will end they're also looking to
produce all their power sustainably
from solar and wind farms on the site
they're also going to take the
opportunity
to shrink this plant a bit to make it
much more efficient they reckon they can
reduce the time it takes to make one of
these
by 60 just by bringing everything closer
together and that will make this a more
efficient
and hopefully a greener place to make
vehicles well electric cars aren't the
only eco-friendly alternative on the
market
hydrogen cars are also being developed
across the uk
and they could be an option fit for
royalty today prince charles visited
river simple in central wales it's a
company
manufacturing hydrogen cars but how do
they differ
from electric options well they're
powered by electricity produced
internally through chemical reactions
between hydrogen and
oxygen they emit no carbon water
is the only tailpipe emission and while
electric batteries normally take
several hours to recharge hydrogen is
dispensed much more like petrol or
diesel in minutes
at a filling station but the
infrastructure is currently
very limited with only 11 hydrogen
filling stations in the uk
nearly half of which are inside the m25
and as hydrogen doesn't exist in its
pure form the production process
is energy intensive and often requires
using fossil fuels
and when manufacturing is taken into
account a hydrogen vehicle
will produce around 120 grams per
kilometer of carbon dioxide over its
lifetime
although if the hydrogen is produced
using renewable energy
that figure could be reduced
significantly well that compares to an
electric vehicle
at around 124 grams per kilometer
most of which comes from the production
of lithium-ion batteries in
the cars well joining me now is the
presenter and hydrogen
car owner james may james good to talk
to you
i know that you're a man who likes his
motors so my first question to you
really
is how is the ride different
um well i i should come clean as uh have
a hydrogen electric car and the battery
electric car because i'm
comparing them in the real world and i'm
trying to take part in experiments i'm
not an evangelist for either i'm keeping
an open mind
but in both cases because they're both
essentially electric cars the experience
is
quiet serene and
polite is the word i often use because i
can drive them very early in the morning
which i often do and i don't
wake people up so i'm a big fan of
electric motoring but i think
both both solutions hydrogen and
batteries
are fraught with potential problems the
problem for batteries is
the mining of the difficult materials um
very unclean mining
the fact that they're still taking a
long time to charge and there's no
obvious battery development on the
near horizon um the problem with the
hydrogen car is it refills quickly but
it's very difficult to find the hydrogen
it's very difficult and expensive
to produce clean hydrogen most of it at
the moment is is gray hydrogen made by
reforming fossil fuels
as you say if we use it with sustainable
energy it will become perfectly clean
but
it's also not very energy efficient but
then maybe that doesn't matter it's it's
a massively complicated subject
batteries are unsuitable for things like
aeroplanes because the batteries we have
would be enormous and unworkable so
i think there's actually room for
battery and hydrogen cars in the future
battery cars are great if you can charge
at home if you're not a massive user you
know we know the statistics most people
only drive
short distances eight miles a day and
they can recharge overnight if they have
somewhere to do it
the advantage of the hydrogen car is is
more that it's
not a solution for the car it's the car
take on a bigger
energy picture which is a hydrogen
infrastructure and a hydrogen economy
so it would really be put in place for
things like ships aviation heavy haulage
and the car would benefit from it the
car as it is benefits massively from the
battery revolution but it doesn't
transfer so well to things like all in
shipping and aviation
this is why i think we'll end up with
both and maybe some other things besides
james you described it as a polite drive
now you're a man who likes
i think the thrill of a drive is the
most exhilarating thing
about driving a hydrogen car is not
knowing when perhaps you're going to
find the next hydrogen filling station
well i yes i do get a perverse thrill
out of that because there's a bit of
brinksmanship
involved um and i yeah i do i do enjoy
it i
i have a very good mental picture now of
where the hydrogen filling stations are
i am in london so i'm in
a lucky position i've got two within a
few miles of my house
and on regular journeys i make i know
how far i can go before i'm out of range
of the hydrogen filler there's nothing
you can do if you run out
if you run out on a battery car you can
push it to a plug and you can plug it in
anyway you can't do that with hydrogen
so yes i do enjoy that
my new hydrogen i've just got the new
toyota um it's got a bigger tank and a
bigger range and it's a bit more
efficient and i find i'm a little bit
more relaxed about using it but there
are still parts of the country where if
i'm going there
in all honesty i have to take the
ferrari it's as simple as that
you poor man my heart goes out to you
and 2030 there's going to be a ban
on sales of petrol and diesel cars do
you think we'll be ready and will
hydrogen
be a part of that mix um i hope
hydrogen will be a part of that mix
certainly for those other areas i
mentioned
like vans big lorries and so on
um i i think i think we can be ready but
i think some of the challenges are
bigger than people are wanting to admit
so with everybody says there's only
eight and a half thousand or slightly
fewer than eight and a half thousand
petrol stations left in britain these
days the number has been declining since
the 60s
but what they're forgetting is most of
them have at least five some of them
have 20 pumps
and they're occupied for a few minutes
at a time whereas
battery cars even with really good
supercharging networks still take
tens of minutes sometimes an hour to
recharge so
even though we've got more charging
points than petrol stations
i don't think it's anything like enough
yet because if you multiply
the number of pumps at a petrol station
and then multiply that again by the
number of minutes you need to occupy an
electric charge you i worked out the
other day that the country needs
something like 1.2 million
so it's not going to be for everybody
and if you are
traveling the country selling
encyclopedias or any of those other
things that people drive around doing
then it's going to be tricky to use a
battery electric car and a hydrogen
car would be nicer if there were the
filling stations i filled mine up
two days ago and i timed it out of
interest which i do fairly regularly
because i'm that kind of bloke
and it took four minutes and 10 seconds
and that gave me a range of 300 miles
and that is glorious
really good to talk to you james may
thank you thank you
well in today's other climate news and
mexico's state-run energy firm pemex
says there's no environmental damage
from a fire near one of its oil
platforms
the company says the quick actions of
its workers controlled the fire
in the gulf of mexico but
environmentalists say that it's too soon
to know if the fire caused any damage
it's thought that the blaze began after
a gas leak occurred in an underwater
pipeline
that connects to one of pemex's
platforms
a new record high temperature has been
registered in
lapland the 33.6 degrees celsius reading
was taken in kivo on sunday the hottest
day
since 1914. finland is one of several
nordic countries to experience
record temperatures over the weekend
scientists say these conditions are
linked to the extreme heat wave and
wildfires
seen recently in north america
the french senate has voted to block a
referendum to add climate protection
to the constitution conservative mps
said the proposal is unnecessary
and could harm the country's business
sector president macon has promised to
organize the vote
after he was criticized by members of
his own party
for not doing enough to protect the
environment
and a herd of elephants is being taken
from kent
to kenya in the first rewilding project
of its kind
the aspinol foundation will fly 13
elephants
currently living at howlett's wild
animal park more than 7 000 kilometers
across the world
to africa the charity hopes it will
encourage the zoo industry to take part
in similar projects
returning animals to the wild now the
uk's development finance institution has
investments
worth more than 650 million pounds in
fossil fuels overseas
boris johnson has pledged to end
government direct support for the sector
so what is going on well our climate
correspondent
hannah thomas peter is here hannah how
does the government justify
this kind of investment well this
investment institution is called the cdc
and it invests uk
government aid overseas in africa
and south asia and it is actually
allowed to invest
in particularly gas-fired coal gas-fired
power plants
in order to support development that's
part of a set of government
exemptions but there are campaigners who
say
well what the cdc is doing is nonsense
it shouldn't be supporting fossil fuel
development
anywhere in the world on behalf of the
uk taxpayer
it is locking developing countries into
long-term reliance on fossil fuels when
it should be doing
uh the opposite and gas isn't a clean
bridging fuel at all it will
stop the world uh getting to its net
zero carbon emissions by 2050 targets
which
we've heard so much about but then if
you speak to people within the cdc they
will say first of all we're not doing
anything wrong this is all within
government guidance and secondly
there are hundreds of millions of people
in africa for example who don't have
access to the electricity
and therefore the modern world that
constitutes an acute
development need we have a
responsibility to meet that need
and it has to be perhaps balanced with
this march to renewables which is
absolutely necessary
but not really that straightforward and
what's interesting about this story is
it illustrates
how complicated and thorny this issue is
very clearly indeed doesn't it just
hannah thank you
now what will you be doing in the run-up
to cop26 well if you haven't decided yet
then
don't panic because plans for the great
big
green week have just been announced it
will take place ahead of november's
climate conference
and will include events such as concerts
litter picks
and nature walks to show how communities
are taking action
to fight climate change well thousands
of people have already signed up
and among them is actor and wwf
ambassador kell spellman
who joins me now kel good to talk to you
tell us a little bit more about the
great big green week if you would and
and what you'll be doing
yeah of course well thank you for having
me it's uh it's a real pleasure to be on
the show i'm a big fan
of the show you're one of the few shows
that's putting climate in the
environment
on mainstream television which is great
um well the great big green week listen
this hopefully is going to be one of the
biggest weeks centered around climate
and the environment and nature
that we've seen here in the uk and
you've said it there as well of course
we've got a bigger
conference taking place cop 26 come
november so this is a chance i think for
really the the country to come together
and
you know get us talking about nature
getting us talking about what we can all
do individually what we can do as
communities
but also you know show politicians and
show our government
and world leaders around the world that
we as a country and the people of this
country uh really want to see some
ambitious commitments taken at cop
uh because we care for we love for and
want to nurture our environment and
protect
our nature here at home and around the
world and i think this is going to be a
real special week where
if we can i know everybody talking about
where everybody feeling things around
kind of the environment and
our local environment around us i think
it could be really really special
and it's really interesting isn't it
because the majority of the public
according to a survey think that the
government really needs to up its game
ahead of cop
26. yeah and
i think that seems to be growing um you
know month month on month really for me
i think really especially over these
last 18 months we've seen
us all kind of find a new love and
appreciation for nature
like never before and as we find that
love and appreciation for it with that
comes understanding and what people are
really starting to understand and i
think it has finally hit home
is there is a real finite amount of time
we've got
to turn things around and we can all do
our own things
individually of course but some of the
big ambitious things that we need to see
unfortunately has to come from our
government
and when you look around at what has the
government done you know pledging is one
thing but action is another thing
it doesn't seem to add up and given the
severity of the situation and i don't
want to be doom and gloom because it's
not what i'm about but
we are at a very critical time and we
are a real tipping point and if we don't
turn things around very quickly we are
going to go past the point of no return
and i think
we'll look into the government and say
your actions and what you're saying
doesn't seem to correlate with just how
much of an emergency
this is and we're all trying to do our
bit and we just need to see a little bit
more from
our politicians and world leaders all
around the world
kel spellman good to talk to you thank
you
pleasure thank you so much for having me
well that is everything
from us for today on the daily climate
show tomorrow
how re-wiggling rivers can help to
reduce flooding
and improve habitats that's at the same
time tomorrow here
on sky news thanks for watching